So for the folks
that are a little bit
more green to the industry.
How does that benefit them,
all of what Aptos is building?
The only blockchain use case
that really found real world use
is financial applications.
For retail users,
this is another option
for them to get into
the capital markets.
Traditional way,
it was real estate,
stock trading,
futures trading, options.
Right?
All these good stuff.
They are great.
But the legacy market
that we are using today
is actually not fair
to the retail audience
because the edge
that you have on the trade
comes not from information.
It actually comes from
how close you are to
the data center.
So that's an unfair
playing field for people.